I was honored that you
asked me to write the forward,
but when you first asked me
to write the forward,
the first thing I said was,
"Girl!
You don't need a forward.
Everybody knows who you are."
And I wrote
what I believe in my heart,
I said that your words
healed our wounds
and resurrected our spirits.
I think it was a shot
of light, you know?
It was just like, "Whoa!"
An infusion of light
came into people's lives.
What's magnificent about
this poem when you analyze it,
there isn't a word
that is wasted.
I'm a poetry reader
and have been for years,
but my favorite passage
or piece of the poem
is when you say,
"We braved the belly
of the beast,
we learned that quiet
isn't always peace,
and the norms and notions
of what just is,
isn't always justice.
And yet the dawn is ours.
Before we knew it,
somehow we do it.
Somehow we weathered
and witnessed a nation
that isn't broken,
but simply unfinished."
I think that saying
our country isn't broken,
it's just unfinished
is really hopeful,
and hope is something
we really need
more of right now,
and you obviously wanted
people to feel that
when you wrote this.
What did you want the takeaway
ultimately
from the poem to be?
I wanted that to be
the takeaway,
which is why I'm so glad
that you just read it.
Which for me, I think,
looking at our democracy
as something that's
unfinished is both hopeful,
but it's also reflective.
It's also interrogative.
Meaning that it both
says we have work to do
and we can accomplish it.
In the poem, I wanted
to speak of hope and unity,
but it had to be rooted
in a sense of purpose
and dignity.
Because I think unity
for the purpose of unity
without interrogation
can just be
toxic mob mentality.
It's not thinking about
what are the reasons
that we're linking arms?
So I wanted to really
underscore this idea
that the American project
is a process
and it's not something
that I think
we've arrived at yet
as a country,
but something
that we can continue
to labor for out of love.
Well, as a 23-year-old,
to have such discernment
and great perspective
on everything
that's happened,
and particularly everything
that's happened in recent years
with the country's
divisiveness,
how starkly divided
we all have become,
how cancel culture
has affected almost everyone,
how the world literally
shifted in front of us
during the pandemic,
but you were able
to do it one poem.
When you say, "And, yes,
we are far from polished,
far from pristine,
but this doesn't mean
we're striving to form
a union that is perfect."
Which I think people
need to be reminded of,
because we keep hearing
"a more perfect union."
We've heard that for years.
"But this doesn't mean
we're striving
to form a union
that is perfect.
We are striving to forge
our union with purpose."